joining us now is the conservative MPS
to John redwoods and Liz truss supporter
hi it's good to see you thanks for
joining us on the program this morning
why do you think that the markets have
reacted so badly to the Chancellor's
mini budget
well the markets globally we're reacting
very badly to the Federal Reserve
board's announcement when they said they
were going to hike interest rates a lot
and we we saw a big blizzard of bonds
setting ahead of the Chancellor's
announcement and then the world
speculators and currencies who had been
raiding the Yen and the euro in in past
weeks turn more of their attention to
the pound and we saw them do a sharp
sell-off in the pound which then
reversed very rapidly to some extent on
the Monday morning markets will do what
markets want to do and these are not
things that governments should seek to
control
governments need to follow
counter-inflation policies that work
which they didn't do in the previous two
or three years and they need to follow
policies that promote growth my message
today is that the government are right
to see the main threat for the year
ahead as a recession not inflation
because the good news is that all the
forecasters say inflation will come down
a lot next yeah and the sooner the
better
so how does inflation come down with
interest rates going up to the extent
that we are are being till six percent I
know what you're going to say in
response to that and I would suggest if
interest rates go up to six percent
we're going to see people not being able
to afford their mortgages and having to
hand back their homes
yes and that would be quite a wrong
policy response and I hope the bank of
England monetary policy committee is
wiser than some of these rumors and
leaks coming out because I don't think
there's any way in which we need six
percent interest rates uh their own
forecast Bank of England's own forecasts
say that inflation will be back to two
percent within a couple of years they
may be right this time that their
forecasts and I think they should be
very cautious about taking more action
because they have lurched from a
monetary policy that was flagrantly too
permissive and very inflationary to one
which is now very tight and I think it's
quite tight enough to do the job we need
to do which is to get inflation done
well then the bank of England is
independent as we know and they feel
that it's necessary to stabilize the
pound by increasing interest rates
significantly
well it's not their role or remit
stabilize the pound and they won't be
able to stabilize the pound uh the pound
is buffeted by huge forces in in Global
Currency markets where uh collectively
the the World Trade has trade far more
money than the British government could
throw at it the last time we had a
policy of trying to defend a particular
level of the pound it was particularly
disastrous policy it was called European
exchange rate mechanism and it first of
all gave us an inflation and then it
gave us a recession we don't want boom
bust and trying to Target the currency
would be a supreme error which would do
damage to our prosperity
not as disastrous for the Pounders we're
seeing at the moment some might suggest
do you think the bank of England is
overreacting
well they haven't done anything yet and
I'm very pleased they haven't I fully
supported potentially an increase in in
interest rates to six percent that's
what is being speculated do you think
that would be an overreaction yeah well
that isn't a statement to the bank of
England I'm pleased to say the bank of
England has wisely decided it doesn't
need an emergency meeting or an
emergency interest rate rise and why
would they because as I said their
forecasts are that inflation will come
back down to Target within a couple of
years and that they have already put up
interest rates on several occasions in
the past more importantly they have
stopped printing money to buy bonds
which I think was one of the
inflationary forces the bank of England
wanted to do something helpful then they
would announce that they don't need to
be selling some of the bonds that they
bought at very high prices at Big losses
they could save to the markets we now
think the bonds are too cheap for us to
want to sell any that would be very
helpful
uh okay let's talk about the
international monetary firm fund then
the uh the lender Last Resort they've
also got very grave concerns overnight
why are they wrong
well the IMF but were very wrong as was
the bank of England over the inflation
which they now rightly worry about
they didn't warn us or the other central
banks in the run-up to the big inflation
that the monetary policies in 2021 were
far too loose interest rates are far too
low and that money printing was getting
out of control and it's a great pity
they didn't warn about that now they
should be looking forward
and as the global forecasts point to
lower inflation in America Britain
Europe as do the domestic forecasts they
should be saying the new threat is
recession I don't want to see people
losing their jobs on a big scale and
income squeeze because uh we're in too
big a recession we should be fighting
recession of course we must be prudent
with finances but the the truth is that
if the austerity policies have their way
and we have a big recession the the
borrowing won't go down the borrowing
was sore and my fear now is the official
forecasts in the United Kingdom which
for two years greatly exaggerated the
amount of borrowing to try and encourage
a high tax policy are now
underestimating the amount of borrowing
we will be forced into doing because of
the world Slowdown
so the bank of England is out of Step
the IMF is out of Step let me put a
story to you that I've been reading in
the Sunday Times Guardian other
newspapers as well interesting to get
your take on this so John if you would
please at reporting that there was a
group of Liz trust supporting hedge fund
managers who attended a dinner a week
ago every one of them was shorting the
pan which means that you know but for
the benefit of others who perhaps don't
they were betting that it would go much
lower against the dollar the paper
reported several of them made small
fortunes shorting the pound the
financial conduct Authority has been
asked to investigate do you think they
should
well I I know nothing of the
circumstances of this alleged meal and
who went so now I I can't comment on
that if people have uh broken the rules
or done something wrong then of course
it should be investigated but I know no
evidence for that I suppose you only
know if they've broken the rules if you
investigated
yes but I don't even know this meal
occurred so I'm not the person to
cross-examine on this but I like most
people uh don't wish to see people
breaking rules and if they have they
should be investigated
um okay
um how did you feel about the latest
opinion polls that we saw from yougov
Over the week well they they was done
over the weekend we saw it um yesterday
uh tour is 17 points behind labor
well I look forward to them improving
clearly that wasn't a good poll but the
the poll that matters as people always
say who are behind in the pose is the
one that occurs when you have a general
election uh I would imagine a general
election is still a couple of years away
uh so I think a lot is going to happen
before then and I will be supporting the
government every time it does things
which raise the prosperity and freedoms
of the British people so that is surely
the way it's become more popular
yeah I'm sure that um this trust is not
going to find it mildly amusing given
that normally you do see when there's a
new leader in post they do tend to have
a polling boost in the first few weeks
don't they
well these are very exceptional times
aren't they and the the new prime
minister took over against this
background of Global Market meltdown
bombs being sold off everywhere shares
falling a lot as well as people sifted
through the the truth of what I've been
trying to tell you which is that we are
at that point where inflation is
receding as the main problem and
recession is looming and that does
require a policy change and I therefore
look forward to around in policy change
from this government not merely some tax
rate reductions but also measures to
promote more investment more capacity
more domestic energy more domestic food
because we need to tackle the balance
payments deficit and measures to get
better value out of all our public
spending so that we control the deficits
in the right way
okay it's great to talk to you we
appreciate you taking the time this
morning thank you